[Music]
what I love about this apple tart is
it's sweet its tart and the crust is so
buttery hey guys it's ink so today I'll
be teaching you guys how to make my
favorite apple tart as much as I love
apple pie I just wanted to find a way to
sort of elevate it and this was just the
perfect way to do it this is the recipe
I've made since I was in college this
was just something really special that I
was able to share with friends and
family
I still remember the first time they saw
it and they were just like wow this is
incredible
this looks so beautiful in a holiday
setting I feel like it is a season where
it's to be celebrated and shared and
it's happiness all over and so this is
kind of my way of contributing to that a
little bit normally I only make this
tart on special occasions you know when
I'm going to a housewarming party or to
a holiday party basically when there's
any event where there's a lot of people
I think what impresses people the most
about it is that because when you
arrange the apples in that way it
resembles a rose laying out the apples
one by one slice by slice I know it
seems super tedious but it's also kind
of therapeutic and it just comes into
this beautiful flower shape and
everything is worth it we're gonna chill
that dough for 30 minutes
Ivy like using Honey Crisp apples
because that's my favorite but you can
use whatever apples you want and then
we're also gonna put in like cinnamon
sugar or lemon juice all that good stuff
and then once it becomes soft enough
we're just going to mash it together
with the fork I said about 10 minutes
but honestly you can go for longer just
to get the Apple softer and become
easier to mash so once you're done
mashing just let that chill in the
fridge so then we're gonna roll out the
dough you do want to be faster because
otherwise the dough is gonna get too
warm and make it hard for the transfer
to happen this recipe kind of goes both
ways you can make it by yourself but
it's also really fun to do it with your
friends which I have done before and it
definitely speeds up the process a lot
more and it's fun it's really fun
once it's in the tarp and just cut off
the excess dough and then just push down
the edges and fill up the empty spaces
and if you make any mistakes or you
accidentally tear the dough apart that's
totally fine just leg rub some dough
back in there then now we're gonna add
in our chilled apple filling I love this
filling I can honestly just eat it as is
pop that part right back into the fridge
while we prep our apples just gonna toss
in some sugar and lemon juice and then
pop it in the microwave for around two
minutes
just so we can make the apples a little
softer now we're gonna do my favorite
part the Rose they kind of make the
apples the star of the recipe then we're
just gonna microwave some orange
marmalade and spread that on to the
apples make it a little more sweet and
then we'll pop this in the oven the last
thing we have to do is just to add a
little bit more microwave - orange
marmalade just to give it a little bit
more shine and now we're ready to serve
I cannot wait for everybody to try this
sharing food with people I think just
makes me really happy it's always really
great seeing the reaction people have to
the food I make I'm super excited I
can't wait to try this I swear it tastes
as good as it looks I love serving it
with vanilla ice cream I think it's the
perfect combination I'm really excited
for you guys to try this and share it
with your friends and family I promise
to love it oh yes
[Music]